BRADY HARAN: So I was out doing
the shopping the other
day, and I walked
past Alphabetti.
What words can you spell?
But then something else
caught my eye.
Numberetti.
What's the biggest number
you can make?
Those evil geniuses at Heinz
know that no self-respecting
Numberphile can resist
that challenge.
And that's what this
video is about.
Now of course, a highbrow
filmmaker like me doesn't want
to get his hands dirty, so I've
brought in the neighbors,
Danny and Emily.
And before you accuse me of
using slave labor, make sure
you watch the end of this video
when we negotiate an
appearance fee.
So here we go, extracting
the numbers.
It's a dirty business.
EMILY: Is that a seven?
BRADY HARAN: Now if you take all
these numbers and just add
them together, you come up
with quite a modest 881.
Then we tried multiplying them
together, and we came up with
a slightly more impressive.
But an even bigger number comes
when you displace the
numbers end on end, making
one big integer.
This is going to take a while,
and I probably won't include
all of it in this video
for obvious reasons.
999 tresexagintillion, 999
duosexagintillion--
688 quinquinquagintillion--
sexquadragintillion--
776 quadragintilllion--
444 septenvigintillion--
333 novemdecillion--
111 duodecillion, 111
undecillion, 111 decillion,
100 nonillion.
That's it.
So here are the digits.
I'd be curious to know what
the biggest number you can
come up with is.
First of all, using
just addition.
Or maybe using just
multiplication.
And lastly, what's the biggest
number you can make if we
bring powers into play?
You can leave a message under
the video, or if you think
you're going to bust the
character limit, and I think
there's a chance you might, you
can also send me an email.
And depending on what you come
up with, we might make another
video about the biggest number
you can make from a tin of
Numberetti.
You've got two options here.
DANNY: Yep.
BRADY HARAN: I will give each of
you four pounds right now.
EMILY: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: You can walk
out the door with it.
EMILY: OK.
BRADY HARAN: Or I will put that
on eBay, and let all the
people who watch my videos
decide what they want to pay
for that piece of paper.
And all the money raised
will go to you
guys to split in half.
DANNY: Half.
EMILY: Don't.
BRADY HARAN: What do you want?
Do you want four pounds each in
your pocket now, or do you
want the people who watch
my videos to decide?
EMILY: How long will the--
how long will it go on for?
BRADY HARAN: One week.
Seven days I'll have to bid.
Seven days from when
the video goes on.
EMILY: What do you
reckon then?
It can't hurt.
DANNY: I reckon eBay.
EMILY: Should go for eBay.
DANNY: Yeah.
EMILY: OK.
Yep.
BRADY HARAN: All right,
there you go.
So there you go, everyone.
They could've taken four pounds
each right now, but
they're going to let you decide
how much they get.
So that piece of paper is
going to be on eBay, and
whatever's raised goes
to these guys.
DANNY: Ugh.
BRADY HARAN: Do you think you
made a good decision?
EMILY: Yeah.
DANNY: Yeah.
BRADY HARAN: So the eBay link
is in the video description,
and will be for one week.
And if you're curious about
what we did with that
Numberetti after we filmed
with it, there's
another link for you.